more than 10 parties are reported to
have taken place here at downing street
and in other government departments
during the depths of the nation's
lockdowns in 2020. a government
investigation is underway and there have
already been resignations i regret those
remarks for the rest of my days and now
for my profound apologies to all of you
at home now pressure is mounting on the
prime minister boris johnson i thought
it was a work event when the whole
country was locked down he was hosting
boozy parties in downing street is he
now going to do the decent thing and
resign
[Applause]
here is what we know
on may 15 2020 a cheese and wine event
took place here in the downing street
garden boris johnson his partner carrie
johnson dominic cummings and matt
hancock are all pictured and 20 members
of staff were allegedly present five
days later an email from senior civil
servant martin reynolds was sent out
inviting over 100 staff to a bring your
own booze garden party at downing street
both these events were during the height
of the first lockdown
at the time people were only allowed to
spend time outdoors on their own with
people they lived with
or with just one other person
on both these days cabinet ministers
matt hancock and oliver dowden held
downing street news conferences urging
people to stay at home this weekend with
the good weather and the new rules i
hope people can enjoy being outside
but please stick with the rules keep an
eye on your family and don't take risks
on november the 5th 2020 england's
second lockdown came into place people
were encouraged to work from home and
all non-essential shops and venues were
closed including pubs bars and
restaurants
eight days later a party is said to have
taken place at boris johnson and carrie
johnson's flat in downing street two
government departments education and
transport have also admitted that they
hosted staff gatherings in december
on the second of that month london had
moved into tier two
londoners were banned from household
mixing indoors but could meet outside in
groups of six
on the 15th the prime minister was
pictured presiding over a round of a
virtual christmas quiz
staff in the office are reported to have
been huddled around their computers and
drinking alcohol throughout
rules at the time said christmas parties
which were primarily social activity
were not allowed
another christmas party is said to have
taken place on the 18th december
allegedly secret santa gifts were
exchanged
and allegra stratton who has since
resigned was recorded appearing to refer
to this party four days later
his fictional party was a business move
and it was not socially distanced
when these allegations first appeared
the prime minister insisted no rules
were broken all guidance was followed
those were meetings of people at work
all the guidelines were observed
continue to be observed but further
revelations meant he was forced to
change tac i apologize for uh for the
impression that uh has been given uh i'm
sickened myself and furious
mr speaker i want to apologize
so what is next for boris johnson all
that subject for an interview for
investigation by superman well it
largely depends on the outcome of the
investigation currently being conducted
by former government ethics chief sue
gray
so far the met police have said they are
in contact with government but have not
launched an investigation
this is now a moment of danger and
jeopardy for the prime minister who is
increasingly facing pressure from both
the public more people died because
people like him weren't taking their own
rules seriously and his own mps i
strongly urge the prime minister to uh
to act now to apologize if the prime
minister has misled parliament then he
must resign critics argue there is now
clear evidence that at some points
during the pandemic there was one rule
for those in power and another for the
rest of us